and get going. I guess they have a new function there. All right, so welcome to the weekly Zoom call.
This is Dr. Kevin Connors and we are going to start off with some questions that we're sent in
and then open it up for questions for everybody. So continuing the question that somebody asked
last time we, that I did the Zoom call was about earthing. They wanted to know about their thoughts
about earthing or grounding techniques and whether that's good for inflammation, whether you need to wear
to have bare feet when you're growing yourself or could you use shoes or could you use
grounding mats? We did cover this last week but we'll review it again. So earthing is the same as
grounding. You are basically discharging positive charged particles that you pick up from EMFs that
you pick up from negative situations that you pick up from, you know, stray electricity
and you're going to the earth that has an abundance of negative electrons and you're discharging those
positively charged particles, protons. So that's a good way to balance your electrical field.
It's very healthy and again that's how that's why it's good to have a pet. That's why it's good to
ride a horse. That's why it's good to get outside and walk the beach. You feel better when you do so
but yes you do, you do to have bare feet. So if you're out walking around with rubber shoes,
it doesn't work. You can also use a grounding mat. If you're inside, especially for us in the
northern country, you can't get out in the winter, barefoot. Using a grounding mat could help ground you
can be very beneficial. This is a grounding sheet that we sell in our store. We also have the
grounding chair mats. You can certainly use a grounding sheet as well. It plugs into the ground of your
house. Electrical system plugs into this sheet here and I do have a lot more about grounding on our
blog. So look at our blog on grounding. We have several blog posts and web pages on grounding so look
at that. Another question came in about dairy products. Which part of them is inflammatory in which part
helps our body to grow? Does inflammation only happen if we are lactose intolerant? I've been told
not to do dairy due to the fact that it helps things grow. Ge is lactose and k-seed free. But are they
the elements that are involved with growth? Inflammation or both can I use Ge? If I have cancer if I'm
told to stay away from dairy products, can I use Ge? We've been asked that question a lot. I don't
fully know the answer whether Ge is acceptable or not. Well, we're looking for dairy products when
we tell a cancer patient to not consume dairy products. It's really because dairy products
contain growth factors. Multiple different ways. Dairy products by themselves if they are
absolutely pure and they contain no contamination from organic cows that you are raising an organic feed
and organic. Let's say we were this was 200 years ago. Would dairy products be good for cancer patients?
The answer still is no because dairy products are meant to feed a baby cow. It make a baby calf
grow very large very quick and then the calf doesn't eat or drink its mother's milk anymore. It eats
grass. So dairy products naturally contain a lot of growth factors. IGF1, other growth factors are in
dairy products and the purpose of them just like mother's milk helps a baby grow quickly. So
if you have cancer in your consuming dairy products typically it's not recommended. When we test
people it doesn't always test as a driver but usually when it doesn't test as a driver of cancer
it's because that person hasn't been eating dairy products already for a period of time. Sometimes
people already know this fact so they come to us they've been off dairy for two years so that it
doesn't typically test as a driver. Often it doesn't test as a driver. It's not that it wouldn't be a
driver but they have been off of it for a long time. So dairy products by themselves contain growth
factors so it doesn't make any difference whether it's a ghee or not. So we still say we should probably
stay away from ghee. It has nothing to do with case seed. It has nothing to do with lactose. Now there
are other reasons. Let's say you do not have cancer. There are other reasons why a person would want
to stay away from dairy products and those other reasons are listed here. You can have it intolerance
to lactose meaning that you don't create the enzyme lactase that breaks down the sugar in dairy
products lactose. That can be because of a genetic defect. You don't produce lactase. Therefore
you don't digest lactose very well and dairy products will upset your stomach because you don't
digest them very well. The more common problem for non-cancer patients is the problem with case
because case seed the protein. So lactose is the sugar in dairy products. Case seed is the
protein in dairy products is very inflammatory. So when you talk about inflammation it's the protein
in dairy products. That's the most inflammatory. Of course lactose is going to be inflammatory
if you can't make lactase but for most people that's not an issue. Case seed can be inflammatory
and you have caseomorphine receptors that fire directly to the brain. So anybody with any brain
inflammation because of post-concussive syndrome, because of Lyme disease, because of fungal issues,
mold issues, anybody that feels like they're having some memory issues, pre-dementia issues,
pre-parkinson issues, any history of concussions whatsoever really should not be consuming very
many on dairy products. It's the case seed in dairy products that fires through that caseomorphine
receptor that creates inflammation in the brain. So it is gluten but that's not a part of this question.
So gluteomorphine, caseomorphine receptors increase inflammation in the brain. So anybody with brain
inflammation issues that I some of those that I mentioned should really limit their dairy products,
should really limit their gluten. But when we talk about cancer, we're really talking about the
growth factors in dairy. And then we could have an entire discussion on the toxins in dairy because
even any commercially grown dairy products are these cows have been given antibiotics, these cows have
been given steroids, these cows have been fed grains, these cows are being fed non-organic things that
are full of toxins. Even organic dairy, well they think organic milk, raw milk isn't that better,
raw milk contains just as many growth factors, it's not any better for a cancer patient. Organic
dairy is that better? Well yes, it's going to be better but still you don't know what is cross-contaminated
with these animals, there's anything you buy organic still isn't ever fully organic these days,
not least purchased that was grown in America, it's not. So but really when we're talking about dairy
products and cancer, it has really nothing to do with the inflammatory issues with dairy,
has nothing to do with the lactose intolerance of dairy has to do with the growth factors of dairy
and G falls into that as well. Now again, everything is in moderation. Can I have a teeny bit of cream
in my coffee? Is that going to cause an issue? Probably not. Can I have a little butter once in a while,
I just love the taste of butter, is that going to cause a problem? Probably not. We're not trying to
create in any of our patients a a religion around their diet or around their supplements around anything
else. You're trying to do things as best you possibly can 90% of the time set some standard like that
for you. We don't want you obsessed about your food, we don't want you obsessed about your your
supplements, we don't even want you obsessed about your cancer because you're supposed to just
okay, I'll stay away from dairy as best I can and I'm not going to worry about it anymore. So you don't
have to be obsessive compulsive about any of those pieces. Next question.
Should I be concerned about anything specific if my body drinks the water out of the coffee
animal and not much comes back out. That's not uncommon. So if you're doing a coffee
animal, you use let's say you got a quart of coffee in you through the animal and oh my gosh,
not much is coming out. Well, usually what that tells you is that you're probably a bit dehydrated.
So if you're absorbing the coffee, you're absorbing the water, the fluid in a coffee animal
that usually tells you you probably have some dehydration issues. You need to increase your water intake
or increase your minerals. So when I get this question, sometimes if a person, this person who
asks the question is not on the line here, but they might say well wait a second, I'm drinking 12
glasses of water a day. How can I possibly be dehydrated? Well, you might be dehydrated because
you're drinking 12 glasses of water a day. What you need to keep and hold your water is a good
mineral balance. Your electrolytes in your body and you can drink too much water and then you will
flush that out and you will flush out your electrolytes and you won't be able to hold your water.
You can actually dehydrate yourself faster by drinking too much water,
but in fact, you can kill yourself by drinking too much water. So make sure that you're not
drinking more water than you're and you're flushed out your electrolytes. So sometimes when a person
says boy, I do a coffee and I'm nothing came out. This happens quite often. But I'm drinking 12
glasses of water a day. You need to cut back on the water a little bit, go down to maybe six or
eight. Make sure you get on a mineral supplement so that you aren't deficient in electrolytes and
causing yourself to be dehydrated. So that would be my first thing. Is there any problem with you
absorbing that water in a coffee and a no? Except if you're doing your coffee and a business in the
evening and you don't flush your caffeine very well and it keeps you up at night. So that would be
the only real issue. Next question comes from a patient who is not on the call here either.
She says, I have been continued memory loss. So this patient has a history of cancer. She started
with us years ago. Her cancer has been in remission for a very long time now. She's doing great,
but she's having issues with memory loss. She's going to another functional practitioner in her
area and he wants her to do these B3 exercise bands. I don't know if you've heard about them. If you
father follow Joe Mercola, he's been big into the B3 exercise bands for probably about a year and a
half now. They are a way to increase your ability to exercise in a smaller amount of time. What they
are is their bands that you put around your arms when you're doing arm curls and arm exercises and
weights with your arms and around your legs when you're doing leg exercises and they cut off your
oxygen supply. So they decrease your blood flow to the area that completely. And by decreasing the
blood flow, decreasing the oxygen supply to your arm while you're doing arm curls, bicep curls,
you are depleting oxygen stores very quickly. Stimulating your pituitary gland to release
more growth hormone because it's your body is sensing that your muscles are in a metabolic crisis.
So you will stimulate huge increases in growth hormone in doing this and you will build muscle
faster. So whereas the same thing happens if you're going to do weight lifting and you're going to do
quite serious weight lifting and you're going to do arm curls with 45 pound weights and you're doing
three sets of 15 and you are going to build muscle. You'll build muscle quickly if you're doing these
workouts twice a day. You're going to look like Arnold Schwarzenegger in a matter of a couple of
months. If you're very serious about weight training, anybody can build muscle quickly. But you have
to be very serious about it and work really hard with a trainer. You're doing the same thing,
but it's taking you a lot longer to get to that point. Is it good for a cancer patient to do that?
The answer is no. So for a cancer patient to do that, what you're doing with heavy excessive weight
training, you are doing the exact same thing. Your body is going to release more growth hormone to build
up that muscle that you're breaking down through weight training. I'm not against weight training
for cancer patients. It is maybe the best exercise for cancer patients, but the kind of weight
training that we're talking about that is negative that will stimulate growth hormone is when you're
like working out with a trainer and you're really trying to build up your muscle told and you're
working out for an hour and a half to eat all these huge sets of heavy weights. The same thing
can take place with these B3 bands. So you're putting these bands around your arm. You can do it
instead of 45 pound weights. You're only doing 15 pound weights and you'll get the same result
and you'll get the same result in a shorter time because you're stimulated at excess release of
growth hormone. Now is that good for other things? Is it good for your brain? Is growth hormone good for
your brain? Yes. Is it good for the rest of your body? It can be. Is it good for somebody who has
active cancer? No. That's the same reason why you wouldn't eat a lot of dairy. It's the same reason
why you don't want to do excess fast work, fasts where you're going to have an increase about of
IGF1 production, growth hormone production. So I am not a fan of these B3 bands for somebody who has
a diagnosis of cancer. Now this person who asked that question is not on the line. She has been in
remission for quite some time. Could she do this for a period of time because of her memory loss?
Could this help? Yes. Is she planning on building up her muscle tone where she's going to look real
bulky? No. So it all has to do with how much you're doing of that. So this particular person could
be fine doing that if she's going to work out reasonably, if that makes sense. So anything in excess
if you're trying to like build muscle tone and really bulk up, you are doing so by increasing growth
hormone. And if you do have active cancer, that's not a smart thing to do. Hopefully that answered
that question. Okay. We will open it up for questions now. Remember to unmute yourself if you want to
speak or feel free to chat in the question as well.
Time. Yeah. How are you? Got special visitor upstairs.
Oh. Is she sleeping? Anybody with questions? Okay. How do you feel about
cord? Cord in the cob. I suspect all cord as GMO is GMO pretty bad for you. So yes, most cord
is going to be GMO unless it's listed as organic. So you can buy organic cord in the cob in most places.
And that's always better. So you want to do your best. Again, it's your do it your best to stay
away from GMO foods. So GMO foods have a lot of inherent problems with them. Are they particularly bad
for cancer patients? Probably no more bad for cancer patients than they are for none cancer patients.
But we want to try to stay away from as many GMO foods as possible. How easy is that these days? It's
not easy these days. So many things are genetically modified. It's difficult to stay away from all GMO
foods. So if you don't in your area have the ability to get organic cord in the cob and you want
to have a piece of cord in the cob, again, everything in moderation. And yes, some of my patients are
extremely strict with their diet. They would never eat anything that's not organic. And then some of my
patients patient here this week that she said that it's very difficult in their area to find any
organic food. So that's really sad because that's all our ancestors ate was organic food, right? Now
everything is sprayed pesticides herbicides. And we know that that is probably the number one cause
of cancer. GMOs are just not good for us. Any GMO cord is GMO because it was round up. It's created
to be round up ready. So you know it's been sprayed with glyphosates. So yeah, none of that is good
for us. Cause of a lot of issues, cancer and autoimmune disease. So you do your best to try to stay away
from those things. Would you discuss how supplements can cancel each other out? I think you read something
like that in your book. If you can find that in my book, let me know because I don't know that supplements
really cancel each other out. What you may have read about is that supplements can have negative effects
on somebody who is doing chemotherapy. So there are some supplements that are oxidative supplements.
So let me explain. So chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent. Oxidizing agents are in effect
poisons. So you're taking an oxidizing agent in hoping to kill cancer cells before you kill
the patient. That's the whole purpose of chemotherapy. It's literally a poison and you're hoping to
poison the cancer cells before you kill and poison the healthy cells. And I don't mean that in a bad
way. That's not necessarily a bad thing. It just sounds bad. But that's really what you're doing.
So if you're choosing to do chemotherapy, taking an oxidizing agent, you don't want to take a bunch
of antioxidants at the same time. So because you're you're canceling out the effects of the oxidizing
agent. So I mean, that's a whole purpose of taking antioxidants. There's your expose to oxidizing
agents all the time. Heavy metals are oxidizing agents. Pesticides herbicides are oxidizing agents.
They're poisons and they oxidize your cells. They can affect your cell membranes. They can cause
cancer. Oxidizing agents can kill cells directly. They can also kill cells slowly and cause cells. They
can be a cause of cancer because they damaged the mitochondria. They damaged the nucleus
and the cell starts in a rapid replication phase. So oxidizing agents can be causes of cancer.
Well, why in the world would I take chemo? Well, because if you take enough of it, it can kill
the cancer cell itself. So you're basically poisoning the cancer cell. So should I take a bunch
of antioxidants like alphalopeic acid or glutathione or vitamin C? Well, it doesn't make sense to take
those when you're doing chemo or at least when you want the chemo to do its job because I'm choosing
to do chemo. I don't want to negate the effects of the chemo. I want it to kill the cancer. So you would
not take antioxidants when you're doing chemo or what we tell people, don't take antioxidants for
48 hours after chemo. Now, it gets a little trickier if you're doing a chemo pill at a daily basis
than we could discuss that later. But typically, when you're doing a fusion of chemo, let's say in
Monday morning at night, a clock, you wait 48 hours before you go back on your antioxidants.
Question is, so that are there supplements that need to be avoided on days when you receive the
IV vitamin C? Well, IV vitamin C, it's argued that IV vitamin C kind of acts as an oxidized agent.
And that's how it's actually helping kill the cancer. I would say no, you don't need to avoid,
you don't need to stay off of antioxidants when you're doing IV vitamin C because I don't
think it's the exact mechanism of action. So no, I would not say, I would not tell people to
avoid antioxidants when they're on IV vitamin C. There is one supplement that I would say that
it should stay away from. And that is the protocell. So when a person is on protocell, so if you are
taking protocell, that's a supplement that we sell that we test people on, but we have a number of
people on it. And those people, we don't have vitamin C. We don't have them on
alpha-lopeic acid and acetylcystine and glutathione for that reason.
Next question. My air doctor, air purifier goes crazy when I use my hair dryer,
showing unclean air even with a brand new hair dryer.
Can it have toxic material in it? Good question. So hair dryers use a heated element and then a blower.
The heated element, I don't know, some electrical person may know exactly what
chemical that the heated element maybe coated with, could be possibly coated with heavy metal,
could be possibly coated with something to keep it from burning up. So typically if you're going to
heat up some coil, you don't want it just to burn out after a month and have people returning the
hair dryers. Maybe it's coated with some chemical to keep that from happening. And that is gasifying
when it's maybe slowly so the thing will last a couple of years, but it's still gasifying and
blowing out into the atmosphere and maybe that's why your air purifier is kicking off.
Well, then our all hair dryers toxic. The honest answer to that is maybe
and that's why I don't dry my hair. So that's not why I don't dry my hair. But it makes me happy
why I'm a guy. No, that's not the only reason. But yeah, there can be toxic things that go that we use
every day like that. Interesting. Next question. When we use the RIF overnight, the Killprom
program kills mold pathogens and H. Pylori. What should we use the next morning to
clean up these toxins to help the liver? So if you're running the RIF overnight, not necessarily your
cancer program, but or if you're running with your cancer program, a mold program or some pathogen
program, H. Pylori, is there something you should do that X morning to help clean up those toxins? So
many pathogens like H. Pylori is a gram negative bacteria. You kill it, you're going to liberate
lipopolysaccharides into the bloodstream and your liver is going to have to deal with that and help detox
that. So can you help the liver? Sure, you can help the liver with the hot pack over the liver that
will help. You can help the liver by doing a coffee at a in the morning by drinking a lot of water,
will help flush the liver. You can help the liver by using things like milk, thistle,
like helping with different bile support phase two, phase two point five, phase three,
any liver support. There's lots of things you could do to help with getting rid of endotoxins.
So when you kill pathogens and you liberate waste, those waste products are called endotoxins,
those have to detox through liver pathways due to sauna would be helpful, things like that. So
think of anything else that you would do to help your liver detoxify. That's which how you could help
that happen as well. Any other questions? Is there a daytime bulb that does the same thing as
the hammer bulb that will radiate further so I can move around the room? There is.
So there is a bulb and you can look at TrueRife's website. He's got several different bulbs.
There's one that stands up that loops kind of like a W loop and it stands about maybe close to 20
inches tall. We've had patients with Lyme disease with multiple kids in the family with Lyme disease
in their homeschooled and then they use that bulb and they run a Lyme program during the day when I
everybody's at the kitchen table doing their homework. That's one that you could use.
That would be the best one. They have the double bubble tube but the double bubble has a shield behind
it and it pushes it in one direction, pushes the frequency in one direction. So the one that stands
up that looks like a W tube would be the one that would go I think it's called the 360 bulb.
So it said the frequencies in every direction so it's best if you're walking around the house.
That's the one I would use. Next question, can omega-3s etacetyl cystine and B6 cause the tumor to grow?
I know, I don't think so. Anything could cause a trouble to grow. This is the right answer.
Would omega-3 feed a tumor? No. Enacetyl cystine is antioxidant, helps stimulate glutathione
production. It's a precursor to glutathione. I just cannot for the life of me think of a mechanism
in any of these cases that it would cause the tumor to grow. B6 could help nerve function.
Maybe if you had a neuroma, B6 maybe I know what that's the only. No, I don't think so.
So no, I don't believe so. Nothing else. Well thank you everybody for being on today.
I get to remember if you have something pressing you can always call and ask that question to your
liaison and you can always email your questions and so we get this with them as well.
Another question is the fruity body of a mushroom better than the mycelium.
That's a good question. I don't know. They probably have similar properties as far as healing
properties. I don't know if the polysaccharides are greater in the fruity body or not. I don't know.
I think most powdered mushrooms are going to be the entire mushroom. It's not going to be one
part or the other. I don't know the answer to that one. Sorry. If I wasn't prescribed,
mushroom is it okay to take mushrooms either fresh or powder. It's always okay to take mushrooms.
Yes, fresh mushrooms. The only thing you have to be careful about by eating mushrooms is if you have
like a candida issue or something or a mold issue. It can be an issue. A powdered mushroom or a
mushroom capsule is you're not going to have that same issue. But if you don't have a candida or
mold issue or it's like that, you can eat fresh mushrooms. Where can the recordings of these
presentations be obtained? Well, they are slowly being put up on the blog post.
So you can look at our blog. It's the best way to look at them. But it's a lot of work getting them
put up there. So just be patient. We're trying to try to start putting them up as a whole thing
and then splitting them up into different questions that will make it a little bit easier for everybody.
All right, you guys have a great rest of the week and a good weekend. Hopefully it's getting nice
and you're back in the woods and you can get outside and enjoy the weather now that winter is over.
Know that I'll be praying for all of you and I ask that you continue to pray for us in the
safety of our clinic and so we can keep trying to help people. All right, bye bye everybody.